Michael Douglas and Catherine zeta-jones
you know in November they will celebrate
their 20th wedding anniversary and they
told me that this quarantine has
literally brought their family together
how are things going at home I must say
as crazy and as uncharted these waters
are it's been wonderful having the kids
from Michael and catheter were empty
nesters until 19 year-old Dylan and 17
yo Karras flew back into the nest for
lockdown Catherines been all over
Instagram her selfies and quarantine
posts are a hit Michael have you thought
about tape talking could you get on
tick-tock okay what is a 1-minute video
on that social media just say I'm
letting the Douglas clan is staying
positive while staying at home and
they're pitching in to help others who
are struggling the reality is also is
that our industry is getting killed
right now in crossfire
I mean there is no movie there's no
television being done so this is a
really crucial time this would be really
hard startup and it's hit us really hard
we take care of our own tonight Michael
and Catherine will be joined by their
pals George Clooney Hugh Jackman Ray
Romano and other stars in the virtual
fundraiser for Kovan relief we all play
our part a benefit for MPT f they do a
fantastic job the cats are alive and
very much involved with a number of the
years Keanu Jen garner and Jon Hamm are
among the many stars who support the
motion picture and television fund which
helps people behind and in front of the
camera for anybody's ever movie ticket
or enjoy the movies this is the best way
you give something back
giving back was also a big part of my
goes late father Kirk Douglass's life he
passed away in February but will not be
forgotten how are you doing and what is
he saying while he's sitting up there
looking down on your efforts dad was was
was one of a kind
we called him up he said yeah enough
with you let me talk to your wife it was
a flirt Illya to the very yet yes is a
great part
[Music]